friedrich nietzsche one of the most
significant philosophers of all time his
name has been connected to a myriad of
ideas and his reputation has crossed the
limits of europe to infect the rest of
the world nietzsche is a man that has
influenced my views and beliefs to the
core and also a source of inspiration
and soothing whenever i feel lost and in
need of direction today i will attempt
something i wanted for a long time i
will try to paint a picture of this
legendary figure while analyzing one of
his most interesting works human all to
human i bought this classic while losing
myself in the endless titles of a local
bookstore it was an instinctive form of
seduction that sprang from my visceral
need to have a part of nietzsche with me
wherever i travel this monumental
pamphlet encompasses most of the
conundrums faced within the human psyche
and attempts to describe and analyze
them in a philosophical way it is packed
with powerful maxims that illustrate
nietzsche's unparalleled ability to
scrutinize human nature and offer
concrete and oftentimes poetic advice on
how to deal with it his writing style is
dense and unique he uses very colorful
language and he plays with words like a
master craftsman plays with his tools
oftentimes the gravity of his psyche and
the psychological tension of his inner
world seemed palpable in his sentences
all the maxims included in the book are
important and highlight the depth of
nietzsche's inner world however today i
will expand on five that stood out for
me
the advantages of psychological
observation that meditating on things
human all to human is one of the means
by which man can ease life's burden that
by exercising this art one can secure
presence of mind in difficult situations
and entertainment amid boring
surroundings indeed that from the
thorniest and unhappiest phases of one's
own life one can pluck maxims and feel a
bit better thereby
the benefits of psychological
observation that is the ability to
observe and understand one's motives and
actions cannot be understated more often
than not we are lost within the banality
of superfluous acts and we fail to
realize how awareness plays out across
the span of our lives psychological
observation is such a powerful tool that
can offer presence of mind amid
difficult situations and amusement
during boring encounters this happens
because we managed to approach things
from a more analytical perspective and
allow ourselves to control the narrative
of its circumstance
to close
if we live in too close proximity to a
person it is as if we kept touching a
good etching with our bare fingers
one day we have poor dirty paper in our
hands and nothing more a human being's
soul is likewise worn down by continual
touching at least it finally appears
that way to us
we never see its original design and
beauty again one always loses by all to
intimate association with women and
friends and sometimes one loses the
pearl of his life in the process in this
maxim friedrich nietzsche highlights an
idea expressed by many thinkers across
history familiarity kills respect and in
a romantic relationship even last
constant exposure to the everyday
nuances of the other person may breed
discomfort and a lack of respect towards
the other person nietzsche logically
draws inspiration for this maxim from
the sad endings most of his
relationships had to face
he was a wild contrarian and could
easily express himself in a provocative
way that would unavoidably cause
friction and conflict moreover whenever
he would allow others to taste a part of
his vulnerable character he wouldn't
receive the appreciation he would expect
in turn he would grow resentment toward
both others and himself for allowing too
much proximity to poison their kinship
this struggle is real and it manifests
itself in different ways throughout our
lives i think that the reason such
concerns are expressed so often is that
we usually fail to strike a balance
between pragmatism and romanticism these
two forces are mutually exclusive but
that doesn't necessarily suggest that we
can't successfully vacillate between the
two the key here is self-honesty and the
establishment of pragmatic expectations
on all levels of our relationships
the hour hand of life life consists of
rare isolated moments of the greatest
significance and of innumerably many
intervals during which at best the
silhouettes of those moments hover about
us love springtime every beautiful
melody mountains the moon the sea all
these speak completely to the heart but
once if in fact they ever do get a
chance to speak completely for many men
do not have those moments at all and are
themselves intervals and intermissions
in the symphony of real life
this aphorism reminded me of richard
dawkins opening lines and unweaving the
rainbow we are going to die and that
makes us the lucky ones most people are
never going to die because they are
never going to be born
experiencing life in its totality is a
challenging endeavor we become entangled
in the trivial issues of the daily grind
and we fail to recognize the vastness of
various experiences life can offer ego
is the enemy here and it creates a trap
we desperately fail to see
this ego trap is omnipresent and thus
our willingness to reach
self-transcendence becomes a distant
hope nietzsche identified this conundrum
early on in his life and realized how
much of an impact it can have on
limiting one's perception when nietzsche
says during which at best the
silhouettes of those moments hover about
us he clearly wants to emphasize how
blind we have become in our attempts to
identify moments of extraordinary
significance hence our propensity to
experience grandiosity is predicated on
how easily we allow ourselves to
surrender to the simplicity and
complexity of those moments the ones
that do surrender are the ones who fill
their lives with innumerable intervals
of significance the ones that don't
become themselves the intervals and the
intermissions
learning to love we must learn to love
learn to be kind and this from earliest
youth if education or chance give us no
opportunity to practice these feelings
our soul becomes dry and unsuited even
to understanding the tender inventions
of loving people likewise hatred must be
learned and nurtured if one wishes to
become a proficient hater otherwise the
germ for that too will gradually wither
i sense a degree of irony in this
particular maxim
i am mainly referring to the last
sentence of the aphorism where he
mentions that hatred must be learned and
nurtured if one wishes to become a
proficient hater otherwise the germ for
that too will gradually wither this
interesting remark alludes to the
possibility that hate is a perpetual
state of discontent that can be
nourished
just like every other state and known to
man one isn't born full of hate or full
of love but one can cultivate a biased
sense of how to perceive the idea of
love and hate the irony in the last
remark lies in the use of the term
proficient when describing a hater's
ability to hate for some exercising hate
might even reach a professional level
and could create a level of dependency
on this catastrophic feeling however
nietzsche identifies that this exercise
is a conscious one and that most of the
time
it is pursued rather than randomly
acquired with regards to love nietzsche
puts emphasis on the idea that love
needs to be learned indeed love although
it is considered the preeminent
feeling it also constitutes one of our
most arduous quests
love isn't something that transpires
organically love is something that needs
to be cultivated if this fails to occur
one will lack the capacity to show love
and most possibly one will be oblivious
to the love offered by those who
actually know how to exercise it
boredom and play need forces us to do
the work whose product will quiet the
need
we are habituated to work by the ever
new awakening of needs but in those
intervals when our needs are quieted and
seem to sleep boredom overtakes us what
is that it is the habit of working as
such which now asserts itself as a new
additional need the need becomes the
greater the greater our habit of working
perhaps even the greater are suffering
from our needs to escape boredom one
works either beyond what his usual needs
require or else he invents play that is
work that is designed to quiet no need
other than that for working in general
he who is tired of play and has no
reason to work because of new needs is
sometimes overcome by the longing for a
third state that relates to play as
floating he does to dancing as dancing
does to walking a blissful peaceful
state of motion
it is the artists and philosophers
vision of happiness
this is one of the instances where
nietzsche's genius oozes from every word
a man of his magnitude couldn't really
refrain from philosophizing on the
connection between work boredom and play
work is the result of a drive enacted by
our desire to satisfy a need when that
need is satisfied boredom creeps in in
an attempt to shift our awareness
towards a different need in that context
boredom becomes one of the most
beneficial elements in a person's life
boredom morphs into the catalyst for the
pursuit of higher needs and aspirations
in friedrich nietzsche's words
to escape boredom man works either
beyond what his usual needs require or
else he invents play that is work that
is designed to quiet no need other than
that for working in general notice here
that nietzsche considers play a viable
alternative to boredom and doing so he
elevates play to a higher level then he
goes on to suggest that there is one
more level a person can reach that
enhances the idea of play that level is
not precisely named and in my regard the
philosopher does so because he considers
that state an idiosyncratic one every
one of us bears the responsibility for
defining that state which results as
nietzsche points out in a blissful
peaceful state of motion it is the
artists and philosophers vision of
happiness
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon either now